un voto a mano alzada por unanimidad
para limitar aún más la libertad de
expresión en Cuba el parlamento aprobó
una ley llamada de comunicación social
que prohíbe los medios de comunicación
independientes en toda la isla Ahora
solo se permiten los medios controlados
por el estado hora de comprender y
emplear todos los recursos de la
comunicación Social para favorecer la
participación la transparencia la
rendición de cuentas para poner en común
es decir unir todos nuestros
conocimientos en función de extraer las
mejores ideas
particularnos y generar consensos con el
auge de internet los últimos años han
visto surgir varios medios de
comunicación en línea de tendencia muy
crítica hacia el poder comunista un
ejemplo es 14 y medio fundado en 2014 y
cuya línea editorial se considera
subversiva varios de sus periodistas
abandona país en 2022 debido a las
múltiples presiones a las que desean
estar sometidos
publicar noticias en estas condiciones
es lamentable no solo hay que soportar
la represión y las amenazas sino que a
menudo te impiden salir de casa o cuando
lo haces te detienen y te cortan
internet la ley cambia entre fuerza el
control del Estado sobre las redes
sociales a partir de ahora cualquier
comentario publicado o simplemente
compartido que llame a la subversión del
orden constitucional será considerado un
delito grave castigado con penas de
prisión